recent histories and you got the
opposite is likely to happen does anyone
think nineteen years in Afghanistan has
improved America look around obviously
it hasn't part of the problem is that
tarp it's like Afghanistan and Iraq and
now Iran distract our leaders from the
business they were hired to conduct
which of course is improving our lives
that's why we hired them so you vote for
them making Cleveland better is a lot
harder a lot less fun than lobbying
cruise missiles into Syria and yet it's
incalculably more important you need to
make Cleveland better but that doesn't
even occur to them for the next week
we'd like to remind Washington what
their basic duty is their basic duty is
to improve our lives and that's why
tonight we're beginning our series
American dystopia it's a close look at
what is happening and what has happened
under the leadership of Washington to
America's greatest cities maybe its
greatest city of all San Francisco it's
hard to recommence is go but they have
effectively done it the reality of that
city we discovered when we spend time
there is even worse than you may have
heard civilization itself is coming
apart in San Francisco right there in
broad daylight on the city's sidewalks
which are littered with junkies and
feces and dirty needles the jewel of our
Pacific Coast is now filthier and more
chaotic than downtown Mumbai India
literally how did that happen
we need to know here's the first
installment in our five-part series but
a warning some of the footage we shot is
graphic and disturbing and as you watch
it remember this this is what they would
like to do to your neighborhood at this
intersection just four blocks from City
Hall drug addicts were frantically
looking for a drug to reverse an opioid
overdose
down the street paramedics were rushing
to help a man who are just overdosed on
the sidewalk this videos messed up it's
very messed up such scenes are becoming
common in San Francisco where the city's
left-wing officials no longer enforced
so-called quality of life crimes like
public urination or defecation or even
open-air drug use a little they call it
san franpsycho Tracy McRae is a
lieutenant in the San Francisco Police
Department
if I went into a store it's full
PlayStation what would happen it's not
under nine hundred fifty dollars you get
a get a citation if I smoke crack on the
street what would happen citation if I
exposed myself in a public park what
would happen
oh no citation if I camped on a sidewalk
what would happen warning maybe a
citation if I broke somebody's car
window what would happen again under
$950 citation if I stole somebody's
wallet or purse what would happen no
force or fair use you just took it and
we interview caught you citation him to
prostitute what would happen yeah no
nothing if I was carrying an illegal
firearm what would happen discharge
pending further review you'd be back out
on the street
police say those citations are handed
off to prosecutors who do nothing right
but in there they will make the decision
whether it will get charged or not and
then then the most times is like nope
not charged
nope not charged many criminals never
even step foot in a courtroom davon
America's 20 largest cities San
Francisco now is the highest rate of
property crime violent crime on its mass
transit system doubled from 2014 to 2018
just ask anybody you know it we feel it
crime is really out of control and
whether it's property crime or even
violent crimes it's it's scary addicts
do drugs on the sidewalk homeless people
defecate in the street smash-and-grabs
happen more than 60 times a day many go
unreported because victims know the laws
won't be enforced our car windows got
busted I didn't bother making a report
you're in the police department
hey we're not immune to that we're not
immune to that at all criminals acts
with impunity because they know there
aren't consequences we film drug dealers
selling drugs in broad daylight to the
police officers know who the drug
dealers are yes they do we make these
arrests to get a solid report we hand it
off I could come back for my days off
and they're back out on the street
services most definitely become more
dirty more dangerous
rather than confront the drug views like
a normal city San Francisco enables drug
use by distributing roughly four hundred
thousand free syringes every month city
leaders say that giving out syringes
reduces the risk of disease of course no
one wants to have something to get HIV
or hexing but the unintended
consequences is insanity
and even though city leaders build the
syringe program as an exchange only
sixty percent are ever returned meaning
they're giving needles to drug addicts
it's like a minefield because you never
know what's coming around the corner so
we give as many needles as we possibly
can well they end up here they end up
here
it is dangerous disgusting and it's got
to stop
[Music]
our producer and camera crew spent a lot
of time in San Francisco and we have a
lot more footage to show you from that
city if you've been there or know it
it's heartbreaking but you need to see
it because this is happening to your
country our American dystopia series
continues every night this week
tomorrow introduce you to a businessman
a small businessman struggling to run a
grocery store in a city where the law
isn't enforced it's hard to believe it's
your country but again you need to see
this